no oh my god he's still top
oh my god he's flying out
yeah again good morning gamers
welcome back to another episode of
minecraft i know
surprise look at ikea tower
in all its glory so beautiful
[Music]
we are nearing the end game we beat the
weather last
battle i've cleaned up a little bit but
next up
is the ender dragon baby the final boss
of minecraft after that we will get a
bunch of cool stuff as well
so it's time for us to prepare for that
our next step is to increase our village
make more pepe i have this genius
contraption right so there's a little
hole here in the glass
and then you put a boat here and then
eventually we'll catch a baby that's
right
and catch all your children rip tide i
think riptide is pretty good
rip tide what is riptide 32
what do you think i'm made of money i
think that's another thing i can put on
my
trident it means i can use the trident
as a means of transportation
uh yes please sven where is my purse
i need it now give me my purse
i don't think i have any money left no
i'm poor again
oh god i'm gonna have to trade with
people far far away
okay give me my stuff i have an insane
amount of pumpkin
okay sven what are you doing with all
the cats
daddy's coming you gotta go business
trip damn if i can
use it i love the trident we gotta
travel far in the south
maybe i should kidnap these people in
the south actually
yeah maybe i'll just ikea bird
did i see ikea bird or am i crazy i
can't bart
you can't ah goddamn
all right fine you're coming with me
ikea bird how did you sneak
with me how did you do this stop
low-key kind of cute though oh
oh we're fine one thing i want to do at
some point
is try and collect every monster in the
game
because apparently you can put you can
put any monster in the game in a boat
we're gonna put the ender dragon in the
boat get in the boat
i think you can actually put the wither
in a boat as well
that's gonna be the next oh god ikea
bird is gone that's our goal with this
play through put every
creature in a boat so this is one of the
first and biggest villagers i
ever traded with and this is where i i
make my stoinks
this is where i own my bread and butter
oh you haven't refilled already it's
been days
my god
no he went into a cactus
i can't ikea burn
okay a bird for real you're beautiful
you're graceful
oh no
ikea bird
get in the boat
you're coming with me if anyone has an
objection
feel free to call the cops why
i can't burn why
oh was i talking to you say bye to your
friends
oh my care bird was like father to me
i love him like my mother
[Music]
everything was going so well until the
fire nation just get in the boat
it's not that hard what is this place
the netherlands why are we riding in a
boat don't ask stupid questions
no no
he was like a father to me the way he
would trade me melons for a discount
i felt truly like i belonged
he was irreplaceable there will never be
another man like
him hey
wakey wakey get in the boat
get in no
listen get in the boat or i'm going to
shove this bed somewhere you're not
going to like it
thank you what happened to your friend
nothing special hey no hard feelings
right
trust me this is 100 safe i've done this
before
get in the boat you think i'm playing my
neighbors
just just trust me just trust me so do
you think that guy is good still gonna
trade me rip tide
about three hours later i know you can
play
well damn we're fast you can place ice
and then that's a really fast way to
actually transport in the nether with
ice
and a boat so apparently
you can take one of the farmers and
place him in your automatic farm and he
will replant the seeds
i don't know if that's true or not but i
mean if that's the case
is that that means i get free labor
uh don't worry about the new guy guys
don't worry about him don't don't even
look at him how much do you want to bet
he doesn't have
riptide anymore
no baby come on guys
okay he still has riptide so that's okay
yeah
he's like whoa guys guys it's raining
potatoes
this is crazy don't worry man i'm just
preparing your little uh
a little new adventure all right enjoy
your new home and uh
job well
what in the world oh my god it's raining
yes this is perfect
and even real what are you doing in my
house
i guess it's against the rules to kick
you out all right uh
you can stay just like be nice
how does this work oh my god
ow sven did you see that
[Music]
wait what oh my god
that's awesome let me get away
whoa
this seems very dangerous i don't know
why anyone would do this
no oh my god
you why did that
oh my friends look what a great job he
did i'm flying away i'm out of this
to disguise and beyond
i'm gonna find jurgen again i'm gonna
find the ikea bird
oh my god it's snowing up here
how tall oh my god no
are you kidding me ah
this is the worst episode of all time
i have a cyan bed and i'm not afraid to
use it if anyone come near me
what are you guys even yes
finally
yeah the circle of life continues little
child
follow me little child
now we place another boat trap we refill
the food
and more baby will come what
what are you doing here all right let's
put some more potatoes and carrots
he's the electrician he's just making
sure it's all running thanks
thanks mr pp really appreciate it
guys there's like food raining from
ceiling
does anyone know where that comes from
this is so strange
suddenly my pants feel like they are hot
mine too look he grew up
curves of vanishing okay you guys are
just getting greedy now
yes that's what i like to see all right
gamers
i am back they're all farmers now come
on
you're my destin new farmer we're gonna
have a great time together i'm so glad
no one is going to escape my prison
unless i willingly escort them out okay
don't look don't talk to him don't talk
to him don't look at him he's batman
very bad man look who doesn't have a job
huh
well we will sort that out for you buddy
don't worry about it
just follow me in here yes
yes oh you're lonely okay i give friend
i'm very generous man people don't
understand
you know actually i think you should be
alone
for no reason whatsoever despite the
fact that i don't like you
and i don't like your bald face where is
your face there it is okay
that's all i gotta say that's all the
reasons i need
let's replace my oh look who's already
started huh
from the boat eh
what a loser what a nerd all right
hopefully this won't get overrun by
zambies
i have protected it this time let me see
well if you like the boat so much why
don't you
why don't you try this
so basically he will work for me
and i will sell him his own crops
now that's stoics so whatever job he
does for me i will
sell it back to him how did you escape
get back in chamber that's right shame
on you
so the idea is to just expand the the
whole the whole way
like infinite i want to have as many as
possible keep making pepe
yeah and eventually we'll have it we'll
have infinite baby
what you're not supposed to be a
shepherd
you're not even supposed to be come out
of here get away from him you don't love
him
that's right you're supposed to be a
farmer
looks like we caught the big one boys
how did you even get there
into the cell
[Music]
why do i enjoy this so much why is
making villagers
go into this
oh i don't know why
look at him i don't know why i like the
idea that they're all brothers and
sisters
even more they're a family of pain
they're a family of oh look who decided
to become farmer huh
okay all right look like anyone's
opinion can just change huh
what is he doing give me back my money
that's my money
damn all right yeah that's right give me
all your money
okay one disappeared that's so crazy
it's time to finish up a tower of llama
why is tower of llama the most ambitious
project i have
there we go thanks just stay there
thanks bro see you in forever
there you go should we make a tower of
cat maybe
wake up feeding time
he's like no i want to sleep oh god oh
god we have to eat it's the first time
we get to eat
that relatable moment when you're
dragged out of bed
because carrots are raining from the sky
all right come on guys make more baby
okay so i like my house
i really do but i think it's uh what do
you think jargon
i think it's time we update it it's
looking a bit small in comparison to
everything else we have around us
um and i want to make it like a
traditional swedish
house i think that could be really fun
as well but to build we must first
destroy
man this feels weird this house has been
here longer than almost
anything in this playthrough
that feels cr this feels so strange
oh my god i feel sad in almost the way
i didn't expect to be feeling fields so
i had this house for so long
hey look who caught a couple babies huh
yeah oh no is this your kids
oh don't worry i'll take good care
no child escaping getting both
child you're coming with me
don't think so child look at this
this the one thing that's been with us
in number one
tree of life
wait why do i hear a tiny one
oh my gosh why does everyone make pepe
i didn't ask for this congratulations
guys
damn i'm rich now oh it's all working so
well
look at that things are going well for
once
in an episode not really actually but
oh look he's teaching his child
to be as worthless as his father come on
all right i don't really have the
materials to to build a house i want to
build
so all right gamers last episode
i blame peepee poopoo oh my god
he's hiding from me now what's podzo
and why did i just spend 15 pounds on it
last episode i
said pee pee poopoo was healing then
wither pig's healing him
are you kidding me the pigmen
healed him you guys
healed him but i was wrong
they actually started as a great decoy
and i feel like the only honorable thing
to do for my mistake my miscalculation
is to make a memorial for all the
pee-pee poopers out there
that fought all the brave peoples
that fought and died so we could defeat
the wither
that's why i want to build a quick
little memorial
it won't be anything fancy but something
to represent
each torch represents one peep
this is actually one of the first things
i ever built in minecraft
i was like hey torches looks pretty cool
i'll just place a bunch of them down
it's surreal to do this like 10 years
later
just but for all the wrong
reasons why people why
oh my gosh i can just right click
[Music]
why has no one told me
there it is oh my god
it's beautiful whoa
that actually looks dope
and i missed a spot okay gamers
as a final ending for this episode i
want to do something
with jurgen we're going to ride out so i
don't know if this works but
someone made it i'll put his info in the
description
so that if you put down a diamond block
and another stall
named pewdiepie which of course i just
happen to have on me
and then throw a sword on it it should
create a pewdiepie boss
throw the nether star and then a sword
did i not do it oh it worked
oh my god it's pewdiepie
it's petty pie and minecraft but wait i
am pewdiepie
oh god pewdiepie has a lot of health
don't hurt me pewdiepie please oh
oh oh
no
[Music]
okay no edit
how is this even possible
so i'm playing on the easiest difficulty
no oh my god he's still tough
oh my god he's flying out
yeah again
no i don't want to hurt you you're
getting don't hurt me
i need to drink milk oh wait i'm fine
no no
i love you you're again don't do this to
me
you're good stop fighting
we can be together i love you
please don't make me do this
back off pewdiepie
[Music]
oh my god all right i'm going for
hardcore dps
uh oh uh oh
this is so smart
back up sven back up i don't want to do
this i don't want to hurt you you're the
only one i haven't killed
no oh my god it looks so evil
it's evil schwein
stop stop spend oh my god the knockback
oh what is he doing oh my god
oh god what else could pewdiepie
possibly have up oh my god of course
wait what does she follow me oh my loved
ones are back but they are fighting
against me
there you go you're in water now
watersheep
damn he's fast
[Music]
oh my god stop it pewdiepie
oh stop swore
swore stop it pewdiepie
did it
oh my god 10 out of 10. yes
headphones where do i put them can i not
put them
on my head how do i use
the chair oh my god
oh my god oh my god
i my chair how do i put on there
oh my god and i can change music
that is so cool wait let me get the
chair back
bob's or gone no watch oh my god i can
ride the chair
what
[Music]
look at me sven we're going to beat the
ender dragon in this chair
thank you so much mcmakestein
for creating this that's amazing hope
you guys enjoyed this episode if you did
smash like subscribe check out the merch
of course
to support the series oh my god it goes
fast
oh my god it can do this
[Music]
okay
all right that's it see you guys bye
you